JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
We'll talk about developer
experience and getting started
with the YouTube API.
But first, let me introduce
my esteemed guests today.
In the studio, I have
Fred Sauer.
How you doing, Fred?
FRED SAUER: Hi, how
are you, Jarek?
Thanks for having me today.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Doing good.
Today's my birthday, so this is
a very special show for me.
FRED SAUER: Excellent.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
then Daryl Chang,
how you doing, Daryl?
DARYL CHANG: Hi, good,
how are you?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm doing good.
Daryl, as you might remember,
has guest starred in one of
our shows a few weeks ago,
live from New York.
He's our intern, going back
to Stanford very soon.
But before we let you go, Daryl,
we need to talk about
your awesome project.
So my name is Jarek
Wilkiewicz.
I work for YouTube Developer
Relations.
Let's talk about the motivation
of this project,
maybe starting with you Fred,
I know you've been busy
working on Cloud Playground.
Tell us what it is and
what problem are
you trying to solve?
FRED SAUER: So I've been a
developer advocate on the
Cloud Platform for
many years now.
And consistently, the feedback I
get from developers who have
been on the platform building
applications, that they're
very happy with the features
and the capability and just
how easy it is to manage their
applications at scale.
But it turns out when developers
first get started,
there's an initial hurdle of
just getting Hello World up
and running.
When all the tools are
unfamiliar, when you're
working on a new platform,
that's when
it's really the hardest.
And if you liken it to a
relationship, it seemed like
we were asking developers to
invest heavily first, download
an SDK, download a runtime, get
your laptop set up, and
then you can try it out
and fall in love.
And I thought, maybe let's
turn it around.
Let's go on a date first.
Let's try it out, get a chance
to fall in love, and then do
the rest of the stuff.
So the Cloud Playground is
a way to start building
applications, small Hello
World, guestbook-type
applications right from
your web browser--
zero downloads, zero installs,
just get going.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And fall in
love at the first sight.
[LAUGHTER]
FRED SAUER: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
This is great.
Well, Daryl, I know you've
been working with that.
And I was thinking perhaps
instead of talking about the
project, maybe you could
give us a quick
demo of what it does.
DARYL CHANG: Yeah, sure.
So this summer, I've been
working on the Cloud
Playground embed for the
developer's site.
So why don't we go to the
developer's site right now?
So in the developer's site, we
have static code examples that
demonstrate how to use
different APIs.
And with the Cloud Playground
embed, now we can interact
with these different code
samples and run and modify the
code within your browser.
For example, right now, we're
on the YouTube Data API for
Python for App Engine.
And you can see that this code
sample for Search by Keyword
has a button in the
top right corner.
If you click this Run/Modify
button, you'll be able to
interact with this
sample code.
It loads the Cloud
Playground embed.
And you can see that there's
a code editor
and an output container.
Now, in order to need to correct
output, you need to
set up a project and get
your API access key.
So click this link here and
follow the instructions.
Why don't we roll the video
to see how to do that?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In this segment, we'll be
talking about how to obtain a
developer key to make YouTube
API calls and
run the sample code.
To do this, we'll need a
registered Google account.
The first thing we want
to is browse at
a Google API console.
We can find this at
code.google.com/apis/console.
Or we can just search for Google
API console in our
favorite search engine.
We'll need to create
a project the first
time we open the site.
Projects are groupings of APIs,
and it may make sense
for us to create different
projects for every new
application that we write.
For running the sample code, we
only need one project and
one set of API keys.
After we enable our project,
we'll need
to enable some services.
Let's click through to the
Services menu if we're not
already on this page
and scroll down.
We'll want to enable the YouTube
Data API and the
YouTube Analytics API first.
Let's toggle the YouTube Data
API from Off to On.
The very first time we do this,
we'll be presented with
the Terms of Service.
We'll want to read the Terms
of Service and Accept if we
want to be able to
use the API.
Now, when we scroll down, we'll
see that the YouTube
Data API has been accepted
and enabled.
We'll click On to also enable
the YouTube Analytics API.
The Search by Topic code sample
requires the use of
Freebase API, so we'll need
to enable that, as well.
There's a separate Terms of
Service that we'll need to
read and accept.
Once this is done, we'll need
to access our API keys.
We can do this by clicking API
Access in the navigation menu.
There are two types
of API access--
simple and authorized.
If all we want to do is search
for videos, channels, and
playlists, all we need
is simple API access.
The key is already provided
to us in our project.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DARYL CHANG: All right, so going
back now to the Cloud
Playground embed, all we need to
do is to Copy and Paste the
API access key to where
it says Replace Me.
Now that we've done that, we
can make the API call.
And all we have to do
is click the Run
button to see the output.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what's
happening right now is the
code that you modified, luckily
within the editor,
gets sent over to the app
engine, executed, and then you
see the results, right?
And this is happening against
the API key that you have
configured in the
previous step.
DARYL CHANG: Right, exactly.
So you can see the output here,
which is in iframe of
the deployed App Engine site.
And we can see that we get
results for the query term
"dog" using the Search
by Keyword API.
Now, let's say that
you want to make a
modification to the code.
All we have to do is make the
modification in the code editor.
So Jarek, let's say you want to
change the query term "dog"
to "cat" instead.
All we have to--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds
fun to me.
DARYL CHANG: --do is make the
modification and press the
Play button.
And again, this is redeploying
the site.
And now we should see the
results for the keyword "cat"
instead of "dog." And as you can
see here, videos for cat.
Let's say that you don't like
the modifications you made,
and you want to go back to the
original sample code that we
had on the site.
All we have to do is click
the Reset Project button.
And it'll reset the project to
the original sample code.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if I made
a mistake, because I don't
know Python well,
I could easily
recover by hitting Reset.
DARYL CHANG: Exactly.
So any mistakes you've made,
anything you don't like, just
hit the Reset Project button,
and you'll be fine.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
DARYL CHANG: And let's say you
do like the modifications you
made, and you want to continue
developing locally.
All we have to do is click the
Zip button to download the
project as a zip file.
So as you we see here, I've
gotten the project as a file,
and I can continue developing
locally.
But you have to remember that
you have to download the App
Engine SDK and any other
necessary files in
order to run it.
So that's a quick demo of what
the Cloud Playground can do on
the dev site.
And I hope that helps developers
get started with
API calls more easily.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Absolutely.
Well, thank you very much
running the demo.
I would like to talk a
little bit more about
what's under the hood.
And Fred, I know you've been
working a lot on this project.
Tell us a little more
of what happens.
How does this all work?
FRED SAUER: Well, the Cloud
Playground, as Daryl was
showing us, consists
of two parts.
The top half of the Cloud
Playground is a sort of a mini
development environment.
You can edit text files.
There's actually a way to
manipulate projects.
And there's nothing really
special about this
application.
It's just a way of maintaining
files in the cloud.
They actually are maintained in
the App Engine Data Store,
and every project has a unique
set of files, which are the
source code, the sample code,
that you're looking at.
What's really interesting is
the bottom half of the user
interface, which is an iframe
that's embedded into the main
user interface.
And when you press the blue Play
button, what we do is we
go out to App Engine, and based
on the URL, there's a
project ID in the URL.
And we use that to grab all
the files that you've been
modifying and keeping
up to date.
And we eval them at run time.
And the server figures
out the results.
In this case, the sample code
is calling a YouTube API.
So we call the actual production
YouTube APIs, and
we get the results sent
back, and we send
them back to the client.
And so what we have is sort of
an App Engine app running on
top of an App Engine app.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Mm-hm.
FRED SAUER: It's a little bit,
maybe, recursive and sometimes
messes with your mind
a little bit.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: [INAUDIBLE].
FRED SAUER: But luckily, when
you use the Cloud Playground,
you don't have to think
about this.
You can think about it as you're
just writing some code
on App Engine that runs.
And then when you're ready to
go to the full experience,
when you think, this date went
pretty well, and now I want to
take this relationship with App
Engine a step further, you
can download the SDK and the
Python runtime, if you don't
have one installed.
You can run this locally, and
then you can deploy it to
production, and you have
a real production app.
And then whenever you like,
you can come back to the
playground and maybe try
something else out.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, well,
this is really exciting.
So Daryl, I know you need to go
back to school, but I was
going to ask you, what are the
types of things you think will
be worthwhile to add?
What are the potential
enhancements that we could
make to this project?
DARYL CHANG: Yeah, so one of
the things we were going to
work on is to add a wizard
to the dev site page.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Mm-hm.
DARYL CHANG: So, for example, in
the example I just showed,
you had to go to the API
console and set up your
project there.
But we want developers to be
able to set up their projects
within the page, itself.
So what I want to do is set up
some sort of wizard in the
site to reduce the amount
of navigation
developers have to do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Anything, Fred, on your side
that you're willing to share
with our audience?
I know we typically don't
talk about roadmap.
But what are the types of things
that keep you awake at
night as far as new enhancements
that you could
add and you are not right now?
FRED SAUER: That's
a good question.
So there's a lot of things
I'd love to do.
A lot of people ask for
various features.
The good news is the
Cloud Playground is
an open source project.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Mm-hm.
FRED SAUER: So if you log into
the Cloud Playground at
cloud-playground.appspot.com,
and you scroll down to the
bottom right, there's a little
link to the Git repo.
You can clone a copy and add
features yourself or
contribute them back,
obviously.
That's what open source
is about.
I think maybe the biggest
feature on the roadmap for me
would be somehow add support
for other languages.
We started out with Python 2.7,
just because it was easy.
You can do eval on the server.
Maybe you want to do
Java or Go or PHP.
Java and Go, they require
a compile step.
So you have to take your source,
compile it, and then
execute it.
So that adds a little
bit of complexity.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: A little
FRED SAUER: Just a little bit.
So maybe we could take Compute
Engine instances and combine
them with the App Engine front
end user interface and provide
support for N languages,
and then just keep
the cranking N up.
But ultimately, I want to see a
very smooth transition from,
hey, we just met.
Let's go on a date.
Let's have a little bit
longer relationship.
And hopefully, this is a
long-lasting relationship with
the platform.
But on each step, hopefully
it's a very smooth,
incremental, and you can wade
into the waters as gradually
or as quickly as
you would like.
And when you're ready, you
can always take the next.
That's where we're headed.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, that
all sounds very exciting.
Well, thank you very much for
joining our show today.
I think this is a really great
addition to our developer
documentation.
It's going to make the
five-minute user experience on
our site much better.
I would like to invite you all
that are watching to send us
your feedback.
If there is features or any
other feedback you have about
this functionality, please
reach out to us.
We're on Google+ and Twitter.
And then, last but not least,
if you would like to help us
take this to the next level,
we are hiring.
Check out
developers.google.com/jobs for
information about the positions
that we have open.
Well, until then, see you next
time live on YouTube
Developers Live.
Thank you very much, Bye.
FRED SAUER: And happy
birthday, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
[SWISHING]